la jalousie la lune ou avec nous alors
on a les cinq jalousie je vais essayer
de trouver deux clis et j'ai utilisé un
chien par jalousie
ah ça c'est ma couleur non pas comme
mettre leurs mots non je pense pas je ne
bois pas vif il aime les enfants j'ai
insulté mon rival en anglais par sms
on sait que c'est pas moi déjà j'ai jeté
mon téléphone dans les toilettes pour
éviter une crise de jalousie
j'ai versé une carafe d'eau sur la tête
de mon rival où j'ai mis un gps dans le
téléphone de mon extrait assez dur alors
les chéris allez je vais cédric j'ai
utilisé un chien par jalousie
je veux dire julien courbet mais c'est
moi le nous sommes à la fac et je vis
avec ma petite amie dans une petite
chambre voilà et je sais qu'il se passe
quelque chose avec un autre mec parce
que tous les sorts elles surent faire
pipi les chiens elle sort pendant trois
quarts d'heure une heure c'est beau
quand certains disent qu'ils aillent le
chien vous allez me dire et j'avais
repéré quelqu'un dans l'immeuble et je
me doutais qui se passe un truc mais je
ne savais pas où ils habitaient donc je
la suis
quand elle sort pour justement les faire
piquer le chien mais je peux pas la
suivre trop près pour pas qu'elle me
voit donc elle se perd dans les étages
et il disparaît donc moi pour essayer de
retrouver l'appartement dans lequel
elles étaient j'ai été sur toutes les
portes
appelez le chien par-dessous doucement
chaque porte en faisant cadeau comme ça
répondait bien à la fois un moment donné
effectivement j'ai fait cadeau et
j'attends moi j'ai su que c'était là
j'ai attendu elle est sortie après on
s'est expliqué calmement et je suis
retourné chez ma mère puisque
l'appartement il était heureux mais
encore le plus à que le bec
youtube
il
elle était qu un autre mac d'un immeuble
dans le même immeuble
ce gars est un mot ci n'était pas totale
mais série je ne faisais pas trop mais
julia et la raison au boucher a vu les
mecs
non mais c'est pas le mec qui était trop
qu'aux pour que le voyage
moi j'ai vu je me suis mis dans
l'escalier quand elle est sortie pour
bien vérifier qu'elle est je suis parti
vite à le ménage ou pas mais c'était
chez elle donc pas tout perdu
et tu sais quoi pareil pour la petite
histoire j'ai vu stéphane plaza il
paraît qu'ils se sont fait un magnifique
duplex c'est sûr qu'on l'ait senti que
c'était à moi aller j'ai insulté des
cocus il a insulté mon rival anglais en
anglais par sms alors les mecs insultes
je pense pas que ce soit maxime kenny
non aux joies et gilles verdez c'est pas
moi non
j'ai insulté mon rival en anglais ferrer
sur notre leader je prends les gens
cultivés ceux qui ont des relents clichy
pas que la banque leur ouvre à moi mais
ça m'est resté
c'est pas vous non plus bien aimé alors
géraldine non c'est pas moi mchugh
maxime c'est mal guette c'est vous c'est
moi vous à m'insulter votre rival en
anglais feu grandi saperlipopette en
honneur c'est bien ça qui arrive à
l'équipe rivale
m
c'est vrai histoire ça faisait quatre
ans que j'étais avec ma copine t4 hawks
avec bague au but une jeune fille de
bonne famille qui nous unit c'est riscle
ni de charme on s'entendait comme larron
en foire et un jour elle s'est rendu
compte qu'elle était très amoureuse
sauf que le problème c'est que c'était
pas de moi non mais ça elle est
amoureuse d'un chanteur anglais à john
lennon à john paul george bush dans le
rock anglais mais indépendant mois il
s'appelait d'apple tom tom sawyer non je
ne dirais pas qu'ils n'ont et l'amérique
le symbole de la lumière du jour
look est amoureuse de ceux de ce
chanteur tom et gerri drogue comme olive
et tom vous avez vous cherché à quitter
l'appartement une fois que leur trouver
un autre établissement pourra pour
l'héberger et moi donc j'ai été un petit
peu de cuir à garder dans son salut
s'achever mais j'ai trouvé le sms de ce
fameux anglais n'ont donc j'ai décidé de
l'insulté par sms tu avais je dit liu
huaqing bastad
un vrai charlatans
c'est l'agression permanente les plus
chauds des plus chauds pour peta en
anglais qu'en français
et au final il n'a absolument pas
répondu
bah oui par un cap et d'épée dans l'eau
qu'est ce qu'un coup d'épée dans l'eau
c'était avant qu'on voit les trois
derniers j'ai un autre extrait dieu nous
dit ce thé dansant tabou cédric boit un
verre avec son cousin
sauf que sa fiancée kelly pense qu'ils
sont avec des meufs et regarder ça c'est
toujours un succès regarde alors à ton
avis je t'ai dit je fais mon cousin de
quoi qu'il se passe mon cousin m'a
tellement ça nous aide pas et avec qui
tu veux te parler
ouais ça va te rassurer lors de quoi une
vision cédric cède à tous ses caprices
basse avoir été rassuré regarde mais à
praticiens veux je crois pas du tout
absolument pas
[Applaudissements]
je ne crois pas du tout le mec il a tout
fait il est très jaloux ici tu es très
jaloux à moi je l'étais vous avez va
aussi offre à vous vous êtes jaloux je
suis de nature un peu possessive
c'est la personne pour sa voûte moitié
des quelque chose je suis possessif pas
jalouse mais possessif annonce assez
atroce sa jalousie en fait c'est un lent
poison mortel c'est le tonneau des
danaïdes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
au logis en sorte de cruche est en fait
qu avec dallas où situer et de la
remplissait jamais tant par laquelle se
perd toute sa puissance ou bien
directement la chaîne mais si comme
général on est aussi content c'est ça
l'a bien vu c'est là pour dire que la
jalousie sas a renfermé sur moi alors je
suis l'amour j'ai mis alors il ya quoi
comme un truc j'ai jeté mon téléphone
dans les toilettes pour éviter une crise
de jalousie ou là ça c'est une meuf
ah non ça mais c'est entre géraldine et
agathe got away again agathe parce que
quand j'étais plus jeune il me madiaga
titre que lui il est très très sûr
agathe 1 donc il connaît tous les deux
mois john wall e du tout alors agathe
c'est vrai ouais mais j'ai un peu
paniqué parce que j'étais avec ma ça
nous regarde pas ouais c'est avec mon
petit a dit et donc on était en train de
s'engueuler ndima plus que t'as rien à
cacher montre moi ton téléphone et tout
laisse moi regarder tes messages
alors donc j'ai évidemment jouer la
carte du nom tu dois me faire confiance
c'est malsain comme relation machin
machin
sauf que malheureusement dans mon
téléphone il y avait des sms de son
meilleur un homme c'est très très bons
amis ou lors qu'ils me chine est grave à
base de tu t'es trompé de mai que je
sais pas comment vas y ça alors mathieu
toi qui connais publiera la zone c'est
qu'elle entretenait un peu évidemment on
va la vie l'amour voilà sûre personne ne
se prend une porte fermée ce qui est
toujours un peu retrouvé ce que oui
allemand truc non aucun homme ne se
prend une porte fermée
j'arrête quand on y va quelque part
c'est que la porte est un petit peu la
paire n'a pas deux
[Applaudissements]
c'était vraiment d'un groupe d'amis donc
on le voyait pratiquement enfin tous les
jours nous tous les week-ends et donc
soit je répondrai pas aux sms soit je
disais arrête parce que je vais finir
par lui en parler et moi j'étais
tellement j'étais c'est sûr ça du
vachement rassuré que tu fais ton
téléphone
j'étais tellement lâche que j'avais
tellement peur d'avoir la responsabilité
de petits murets reproche genre tu m'a
fait perdre mon meilleur ami machin que
j'ai jamais rien dit donc ni s'y montre
moi montreux marc machin et j'ai fait
mine d'être d'être un peu mal est
toujours je vais aux toilettes et je
sais pas ce qui m'a pris j'ai jeté mon
téléphone dans les toilettes ou de
panique et j'essayais de tirer la chasse
sauf que ça passe pas du tout à sa façon
il était fier pour va essayer non je
m'essaie mais de l'intérieur gagne pas
autant bah oui oui donc je suis je me
suis tapé le dégât des eaux sur rtl
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
group et donc du coup bas et ça s'est
très très mal fini m'a demandé ce qui se
passait donc je lui ai dit bon bah voilà
il a demandé les captures d'écran des
sms à son meilleur pote et voilà du coup
ce n'était plus du tout a mis parce
qu'en plus on les capture d'écran le mec
qui me fait je suis désolée elle m'a
jamais répondu j'ai insisté gilles c'est
une histoire là là ça fait peur ça fait
peur franchement ça fait peur et oui et
donc est malheureux et vous le savez
elle ne sortira jamais qu'un plombier
récupérer téléphone elle et elle est
très très mal
allez j'ai versé une carafe d'eau sur la
tête de mon rival gilles neau et moi je
les trouvais direct on se regarde tous
genres et du mathieu anneaux carlo
non moi j'ai une histoire n'était pas
raconter parce que c'est pas je ne veux
pas d'accord robert c orps oui alors
paris bourges au non moins d'eau mais
aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sipa des votes de ce siècle en même
temps alors nous sommes au mois de mai
1995 et une vague de chaleur s'abat sur
la capitale fin on n'a pas demandé de
donner à mes tours pour moi j'ai
quelques jours de congé oui et donc je
me dis plutôt que de me reposer qu'est
ce que je vais faire je vais suivre
christiane avec laquelle j'entretiens
une petite relation paix quelques
semaines christian kill esthéticienne
connaît elle est laide qu'elle n'était
pas légal et donc je la laisse partir au
travail et ensuite je vais me poster
devant son travail elle était vendeuse
dans du prêt-à-porter à montparnasse et
qu'est ce que je fais je mens bus que
comme ça comme ça moi je vous vois quand
elle va manger le midi je la suis elle
va acheter son sandwich et un jour au
bout du quatrième jour je vois un gars
qui attend devant la boutique je dire
très bien le gars at on est haut dans ma
tête je dit attends attends attends
attends il attend qui se garent un beau
brun c'est physique facile pas très
intéressant et donc elle sort du magasin
il la voit discuter avec le bras non là
je me dis à quelque chose j'ai bien fait
de la suivre donc je les suis his
installer une terrasse
il faisait beau je les entends rigoler
vous me connaissez la pression monte
je dis je vais y aller donc j'y vais et
ni une ni deux je dis alors là qu'est ce
qui se passe
bon appétit je prends la carte d'hôte
dans la gueule du gars et ça se trouve à
fédéral et la colombie pas d'appétit
et lorsqu'à rugby m'était complètement
con c'est mon frère m'a largué le soir
même ouais ouais
jaloux ressemblance est un pas mais qui
avait une ressemblance mais non
exactement comme elle est et châtains et
lui brin voilà c'est pour ça que disait
- jamais j'ai imaginé ça arrive quand
vous avez la même barbe alors aux vins
dernière histoire j'ai mis un gps dans
le téléphone de mon exploit en date est
élaboré un qui vous dit que vous kevin
kelly non moi je suis moche chikhebbih
parce que ça s'est passé il faut avoir
un délire c'est vous qui avez mis un gps
dans le téléphone avec ces mares que ce
que kelly elle était tellement jaloux
scala et miri gps dans le portable de
son ex copine qui m'a aidé et voilà elle
m'a dit si tu veux je peux faire ça pour
toi moi je dis avec plaisir mais comment
on fait pas sens pas piquer son portable
et c'est elle emprunte tactile pour voir
l'activé noise il faut qu'on attende
qu'il dorme il habitait au rez de
chaussée il ya ma commune je te passe le
portable à travers la fenêtre et humains
stahl le truc j'ai dit mais tu es sûr y
verra pas il me dit m dit non il verra
pas c'est vraiment un deuxième
calendrier il est rare jamais fini
deuxième donc du coup un soir il s'est
endormi
j'ai pris son doigt j'ai ouvert son
portable c'est arrivé on était jeunes on
a vu ça nous faisait rire en plus
hostile dernière non ces empreintes
tactique pas si longtemps
j'avais pas de quel jalousie vous parlez
moi je déteste ça tue la dtcc qu'il
était déjà suspect donc c'était vraiment
pour me dire si ces suspects pas moi je
vous faisais suspect lahoucine à tapas
ouais ouais je sais rien des monts des
liens conclusion le week end après il
m'a dit qu'il était chez sa mère il
était au métropolis or l'île non il est
tombé très bas ventre et sion ouais
metropolit et il est avec eux me fous
pas à je sais pas je sais pas mais je
les quitter